[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et cherche bidou notre a perdu chercher
une route
encore un matin du pire du monde à
éteindre
le feu
[Musique]
plus loin
les voix se taisent et tout bien les
autres la nuit d'amour pour quelques
heures
la zone et
j'ai besoin de
mettre ici entre l'Union c'est la
violence l'ennui je m'en sortirai je le
promets et si le bon joints
envole-moi au revoir
[Musique]
je te donne ma voix
ce que j'imagine est-ce que je crois je
te donne
[Musique]
tout ce que je pensais que je suis mais
dans mes défauts mais plus belles
chances mais
[Applaudissements]
ça
[Musique]
je te
connaissent mes expériences je te donne
[Applaudissements]
l'héritage d'Allemagne de Vénus il y
avait Michael Jones et là que j'adore
Michael toujours sympathique tes frais
là je bénisse
il y a ses phases c'est face elle est
magnifique
[Applaudissements]
et Marie Cooper
alors tu nous avais parlé d'une surprise
je rappelle quand même qu'ils sont au
Dôme c'est le 10 mars c'est là c'est la
semaine prochaine donc de Paris en
tournée dans toute la France moi je me
demande si je vais peut-être pas passer
au dos de Paris c'est un jour c'est un
dimanche c'est quoi ça
mais c'est la merde
qui traînent
mais il reste en place
il y avait une surprise c'est quoi la
surprise donc on a un petit surprise
pour toi non c'est vrai c'est quoi tu as
le droit de chanter c'est quoi
[Musique]
encore
je marche dans
la vie
tout seul
[Musique]
je suis riche de sa mais ça ne s'achète
pas je m'en fous
je m'en fous
[Applaudissements]
de nos films
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je marche seul
dans les rues qui se donnent
et la nuit me pardonne je marche seul
[Applaudissements]
en oubliant
je marche seul
[Musique]
que n'est pas qui résonnent
je marche seul
dans la vie des hommes
quand on vit maintenant
je marche
[Musique]
pour me noyer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et même si le temps presse
même s'il est un peu court
si les années qu'on ne laisse
que minutieux
[Musique]
et même si l'on arrête
et s'ils ont brisés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au bout de mes rêves pour la raison
s'achève tout au bout de mes rêves
j'y vais au bout de mes rêves
je te coudes pour la raison s'achève
tout au bout de
[Applaudissements]
je peux faire je peux faire je peux
faire là-bas
ça va pas là
c'est pas le retour c'est insupportable
je ne le fais pas
j'en ai rien à non mais je te le
dis j'entends rien là mais
le mec chanteur Jean-Patrick tu mets
plus de retour
non mais je te le dis le concert on le
sait on le fait pas en août
on sera jamais prêt pour Saint Jean de
Luz
vas-y
5 pour toi
[Musique]
j'ai trop saigné sur les Gibson j'ai
trop rooté dans les
il y a toutes les caisses qui me résonne
et quand je me casse voyage je raffole
je change le son de ma mémoire 3 notes
de plus c'est un peu d'amour moi quand
je suis trop court quand je suis trop
tard
cet arbre court pour une autre histoire
et quand la musique est bonne
quand la musique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas la musique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok pour celle là c'est bon
alors attends j'aimerais ouais
on a quoi d'autre
je bosse là haut tu me fais chier
excuse-moi
[Musique]
jusqu'à ses
Chloé
[Musique]
vivre descendre
à trouver
des
ombres
[Musique]
j'ai voulu créer
six mois sur blanc
que je fasse
pour que je sois
rien
ne t'efface
je pense à toi oh
là là on a pas envie de parler
de partir on n'a pas envie de laisser
partir alors quoi attends tu vas pas qui
tu les fais chier là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chant de bataille
aurait été meilleur au pire que ces gens
si j'avais été allemand
merci d'humiliation de rêve et
d'ignorance
[Musique]
le riz de rêve et de revanche c'est tout
faire
aurais-je été de ces improbables
conscience
là au milieu d'un
taureau
si j'avais grandi dans les docteurs
Versace
[Musique]
aurais-je eu la force sanséric contre
les miens
que toi et ton truc demain c'est pas la
villa et quand le vin blanc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu es de ma famille de mon ordre et de
mon
celle que j'ai choisi celle que je
ressens cette année de simples
tu es de ma famille bien plus que c'est
le sang et prenez le second dans cet
écran je pense
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
faut pas tout faire
alors déjà on va pas faire comme toi
déjà on va faire calme-toi déjà après on
fera comme toi déjà on va faire
calme-toi déjà ah c'est beau
franchement
[Musique]
elle a fait un bébé toute seule
le concert
l'héritage avec Michael Jones c'est
toute la troupe le 10 mars